if you're a gay couple and you have a
baby you're fuing sex
[Music]
trafficking do you guys know who the
tuber scum the quartering is I call
everyone tuber scum by the way I watch
the quaring a
lot he's a
tuber everyone is but what is scummy
about this person's so he um he does a
lot of right-wing content which is fine
people have opinions about different
stuff but recently um he started so
Shane Dawson just had um babies with his
husband Ryland right and um the
quartering is basically calling him out
saying like you're this is sex
trafficking this is child sex traff
because they're two gay men who had a
surrogate birth their baby their babies
had twins that's just like Rich
privilege but that's not sex trafficking
not sex trafficking and like and so he's
out there basically bombing throwing
bombs at Shane and Ryland that's crazy
oh really because he's like can't get
out of the [__] right-wing media Echo
chamers [__] is that just how they get
views they just can say wild crazy [__]
like that even though it's not true
that's how they drive of Engagement I
don't know I think I think sometimes
people just really do hate other people
to right like I think way this is yeah I
think this is one of those situations
where it's like you're just so in the
machine like all the time that you just
copy and paste belief systems across so
the quartering guy that's his actual
take or is he reading a take from an
article that he's like he's been like
Twitter bombing this constantly yeah
that's really disappointing man that's
his money maker though right yeah I mean
that's I don't know I don't know I don't
know I don't want to be too cynical cuz
I think that he's being so cynical so
you know if I'm so cynical about him and
what he cynical cycle yeah right but
like this is like the most cynical take
ever that you could have and he attacked
Dave Rubin too cuz him and his husband
did the same thing of like having a
surrogate deliver babies for them so
they're two gay guys raising kids some
people are like that's [__] up all it
trafficking yeah what's his definition
of sex trafficking right yeah what do
does he think that he's going to raise
these kids to Bone them or something
well he's been posting he's been posting
Links of Articles of there was a couple
who had adopted these two young boys
we've done a couple stories that's dark
as hell and it's crazy but it's also not
the norm so he thinks that every single
gay couple that either adopts or has a
surrogate will end up boning and selling
their kids that's how he's talking a
little unfair because it's like when you
look like if you're going to look at
data spreads it's like you're going to
see a lot more straight families like
dude imagine the guy that agrees with
the people that agrees with this guy
they're like wait so gay people don't
buy babies and then they're what I don't
get about like a lot of these extreme
like commentators and stuff they always
talk about like individualism and you
should judge a person by their character
but then they go around and like do the
same [__] and and and generalize well
they go like not all Republicans hate
gay people but then or or anything like
that and all Republicans are blah [__]
and then all of a sudden it's like but
hey every time this happens it's sex
trafficking it's like dude that is
that's that's a h hell of a reach I mean
it was it was closer when they were
criticizing Madonna for taking kids from
Africa and then dressing them up in like
women's like that was at least closer I
agree that's kind of funny though like
this is just that's normal yeah I don't
I mean just gay dudes trying to have a
kid like all right gay having trying to
have a kid equals the worst possible
outcome I know that's crazy copy paste
and that like that is crazy that is that
is I always thought well I don't know
the stats behind like you know what type
of I guess like upbringing people go
through by having like like a like a gay
gay couple as a parents right so like I
think it's healthy to have a diverse
group of family members from age and
gender and whatever cuz then you just
have so many different things to kind of
learn from instead of like if the
family's all boys it's kind of hard to
get a realistic idea of how Society
operates especially if you have no
relatives and you stay home all the time
right you kind of get a skewed world
view but then I think um what what ends
up happening is
like what however these kids are raised
if they're adopted or or if they're like
with the surate or whatever it is like
I'm like if there's orphans out there
not not serg I mean if there's people
out there that need to be adopted and
gay couples can adopt them and you're
not going to do it then why stop them
from doing what I'm saying but then they
would there were people who definitely
argue against that because they go oh
it's a guarantee they're going to be sex
traffic right oh and and then that's
like saying oh oh the stats are high on
on on black folks stealing so we can't
bring them in the store cuz they're
going to steal like they wouldn't use
the same argument on that that's like
[__] yeah so why would they
generalize in the same light well one
thing that I do agree with though is
I've never met a person who was raised
by Straight parents who's [__]
up not one time cuz aren't there stories
about like straight couples who create
like group homes and adopt a [__] ton
and just collect welfare checks yeah
that's the thing
too but gay people would do gay people
would do that but it's like it's like
the freedom to be able to have a kid in
this country is like that's it's a
non-negotiable it's like you can have
somebody literally with massive debt no
income they can have a kid no one can
stop them and no one will even comment
on it but then here you have Shane's
[__] pretty well off like they're
going to have yeah two people with
felonies can to have kids absolutely
yeah and the worst you can get pregnant
in
jail but the surrogacy stuff I think is
another layer of like it's kind of new
and people don't know what to make of it
how how does that part work do they
choose the mom and then they
like between the Shane and his husband
they choose which sperm to use like how
does I assume so one of each there and
then they just Ed their her egg right
and so it's like partially her yeah or
they should have both the sperms like
inserted at the same time into the egg
and see which one is the strongest so
they both come in it's just pretty
unrealistic to expect they're both gay
in a country where you know you have
freedom there's never going to be
anything that stops people from like
doing something just because the rate is
even a little bit higher in their
whatever category you know you'll just
keep like dividing it and dividing it
and be like oh look it happens more
because of this tiny percentage it
doesn't matter so no but if if that
happens then we have to have court order
and make sure it can never happen that's
what I'm saying I I don't get it I just
don't think it'll ever like change like
everyone has a shot to have a a terrible
kid or like do whatever crime they want
to do everyone has the same [__] shot
sadly that's true sadly it is it is cuz
it's not an idealistic world yeah it's
the reality of it stop it from happening
before it happens that's [__] crazy I
don't know I think it's just all these
things now that we're we just it's like
it's not oh I guess unnatural isn't the
word but yeah it is cuz you have to use
science to make it happen right so now
with new tech there's going to be new
problems or new conversations of what's
moral yeah well I got a buddy who had a
kid through a circuit and like is that
like [__] up no I don't know and they
could be too straight parents sometimes
straight a lot of well it was I think it
was originally made for straight couples
like the intention INF yeah people who
couldn't have kids Yeah Yeah well yeah I
mean what are the ethics I mean I I have
a friend too that that did it through um
that thing where you have a bunch of
possible babies in like a pet tree and
you pick the healthiest one like is that
[__] up is that in a way yeah cuz I
mean IVF is that IVF is like designer
baby style paying a top dollar for that
[__] it sounds unethical n it sounds
smart dude I know a lot I know a couple
of people who are just opting out of
having a baby with a partner and they're
just doing it themselves you ever you
ever heard of that [__] called a couple
moms I know a couple people do that [__]
that's something else and I and I wonder
I'm like I wonder what they're what do
you mean they do like they're just going
to be single single parents dude that's
like having a like a pet almost yeah but
I don't know man I just feel like that
must be hard yo it is hard though to do
it by yourself single parents statistics
are aren't that
exactly D maybe they just want to live
their life like choose a different path
other than the stere no for sure for
sure but you know there's sounds like
all of them are coping to me all of them
every one of them no that's why I'm
saying that's why I was saying like
obviously some people's reasons for
having kids is all different but
sometimes people do look at having kids
it's like oh I have a thing I can take
care of like you know it's like it's
more for them than it is for no for sure
and I wonder how healthy that is to but
that that's the sucky thing is that
straight people all day long can have
whatever reason they want to have a kid
and it's okay no one bats an and like
like Steve saying just cuz they're gay
these are sex trafficed babies well to
that group of people yeah it's a hell of
a
reach I mean if you want to talk about
statistics right like gays typically
make more money like they they're top
earner couples cuz it's two guys two
guys and and um on top of that guys
usually love to work like almost
obsessively if uh and then if two of
those guys get together they make a [__]
ton of money so they have a ton of
resources right but then like what about
a broke ass couple that has 10 kids on
welfare and then they're dumbass [__]
and they don't like feed the kids right
and then they all produce like you know
yeah some more like um issues in society
rather than a gay couple that [__]
has one kid some people that's the
America that they yeah but at least
they're not trafficking humans yeah but
that this is like to me the welfare
argument right where they go people go
well there's welfare queens and they're
like trying to stack up all these checks
and like all this [__] and that's all of
the people on welfare it's like yeah
dude okay it's all the people on welfare
I'm sure right sure yes the people who
are exporting the system yes that is
very bad that is why we call it
exploring the system but but a lot of
them are temporary cuz they're just down
and out and then they get back on their
feet so it's like they're kind of
picking the most extreme shittiest
shocking case and say therefore it
should never happen yeah and penalizing
the good people within it yeah they're
not looking at the stats and don't
pretend to be a big freedom fighter and
[__] if you're going to try to limit
people's freedom just take care of your
kid that's the thing like their own
about the double standard of like the
extreme left and extreme right like
don't they understand their two sides of
the same coin they're trying to control
people they're basically the same
[__] telling the other person
that you know they're infringing on the
rights and they're Hitler and all this
[__] and it's like but you guys are both
[__] idiots that's what makes it even
more difficult when when you're hearing
someone talk that makes money from
talking then it's like oh is there opin
truly this or are they just like stoking
the fire they're like living outside of
that that's why it's really very like
comforting that we don't make money here
seriously that's why we could be really
honest we call like it is we're not
polarizing people enough
man should we start saying that stuff
should we start saying try it right now
if you're a gay couple and you have a
baby you're [__] sex trafficking like
that damn Nick I didn't know you felt
that way is this going to get a million
views just clip that guys I'll I'll say
it more I'll say it more you know where
we [__] up though
is we don't just stick to one side we
keep going back and forth from different
sides we they think one one day they
think we're right-wingers and the next
day they think we're super left we're
right Wingers we're right wiers yeah
like today so we lose both we lose both
fans I've been called woke Steve before
and I'm like that I'm like that is maybe
the most legendary my favorite was the
the the Trump supporting Overlord right
here the white Mastermind of the the guy
who refuses to film unless we go to
Trump
Tower yeah that's part of the beauty of
it
man